first shop get the chicken stuffed and
roasting
now we all know
you love chicken i do
but we're gonna do it's a way that daddy
used to eat it in paris
okay now i'm gonna hold that up okay
season
inside please why is it yellow because
it's a corn-fed chicken obviously he's
corn and if you eat lots of corn
turn yellow turn yellow now what are
those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah a little taste
nice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please
now
chilies when you hear that noise is that
made
the seeds have come out let's try take
off the tops
we're going to add the chilis to the
chickpeas in
and then zest the lemon in there please
you love your zest
i love my zest you're absolutely right a
little glug
of olive oil come on holes don't worry
about your nails now
come on baby you can do it now time
you peed off all those wonderful little
butts see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin
now what's that tarragon what's this
slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little bit
anna cd
yep so imagine that flavour going into
the chicken
that's going to be delicious now nice
soft butter
in with a tarragon
is that lovely yeah now i want you
gently
to put your fingers through there and
just so we get that butter under there
but i need those small beautiful little
hands ew
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done i want you
to get a nice handful of butter
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide
and that's how you get all that
wonderful yeah
butter running down and the breasts stay
nice
and moist and like you yeah
all those chickpeas in there nice your
hands have never been so dirty have they
no here we go good and push down
come on okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic shall wash my
hands
no not yet we lay the garlic
onto the tray now onto the garlic
salt pepper that keeps skin nice and
crispy
and then i'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that will stop the butter from
burning
and look at that please open them door
thank you
there she goes beautiful good job
thank you really good nice to see holly
get our hands to that door
i think we all agree
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower
guaranteed to wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy peaks
gently fold in ground and chopped
hazelnuts
[Music]
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
[Music]
top meringues with more finely chopped
hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes and the trick to
stop them cracking
is to turn the oven off and let them
cool inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool whip the cream until
it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your tower with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love
but be warned they'll all want second
helpings
[Music]
the chicken's in the oven and the
desserts sorted now
for a big easy green salad so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
dijon
dijon dijon a nice little
squeeze of honey love honey
good a little splash of
aged balsamic and this is your favorite
this one isn't it
i just like the it has a nice sweetness
but then it has
a bitterness to it too nice
thanks to virgin why do we have to use a
whisk not just a
spoon the purpose of using a whisk
is so it can emulsify and more
importantly you're bringing all the
ingredients together
taste
it's so yummy that is delicious isn't it
a good tip to loosen any vinaigrette and
give it a lighter taste
is add a spot of water now the juice
of a lemon squeeze the lemon in nice
now use some butter lettuce start
placing the salad
around the outside this one is a la la
rosso
okay so we'll put that one on the inside
we're still making a nice flower and you
put your heart in there
oh it's just like a flower that's
exactly what i'm trying to do
a nice beautiful flower
now from there
you crisscross your avocado what does
crisscrossing do instead of just
exciting i'll show you now you put your
spoon in there and look that's so cool
got all these nice little bits i want
you to sprinkle those little bits in
here
i'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend it's gonna be
extraordinary
that romantic dinner the roast chicken
the beautiful salad
okay yeah to the way your father taught
you and how nice will that be all three
of us sat down and eating at the same
time
very nice you gonna do that with megan
all of you all of you and i'd read the
chicken
okay now
look at this beauty that looks amazing
doesn't it right so a little bit
of salad drizzle
drip drip drip nice what i'm going to do
now is squeeze
all that garlic how soft
and beautiful it is smells amazing the
lemon
that we stuffed inside the chicken
roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through
look at that nice garlic puree
i'll tip all my chickpeas
in there from there some of your vinegar
in now you crush them
and because they're still nice and hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree
the rich delicious creamy vinaigrette
the chilis i can guarantee you young
lady
that they are the best the finest
the most delicious chickpeas you've ever
tasted
[Music]
go on then it's yummy right
in now little drizzle
extra virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on chickpeas and that is a roast chicken
fit for a kingdom
this looks really yummy
let me pass the salad out please and
i'll carve the chicken
whole roast chicken stuffed with
chickpeas so with a big green salad
it's always a winner with your buddies
work mates or family
megan you gonna help with the duck danny
your favorite yes
it is now how's your boyfriend
right i'm going come on
that woke you up didn't it so what do
you love most about duck
the dipping sauce the dipping sauce i
love that let's get the duck in the oven
first
let's get a bit of salt in there please
then some pepper
thank you some spring onion garlic and
ginger now why do you think we pour that
in there to season it and flavor it
how come you put them in hole like that
and not smaller it's going inside
i'm not using it for sauce or anything
so it's just gonna make it really nice
star anise sorry so what happens
as the duck roasts on the outside it
creates this really nice perfume
aroma inside tuck that in there
to get it spicy rub all that chinese
fire spice
yeah over almost like you're massaging
good so make sure you get it all in
even the little wings you know
underneath there just like i used to do
to you my bath
i used to wash your little handys
i know those days are long gone i know i
know i know i should die
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there
yeah so we're gonna put it on this
little bench okay
and that goes there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside
all that fat is gonna render inside the
breast so therefore it's gonna get all
nice and juicy
yeah right ducks in three and a half
hours
at 160 degrees celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part i think it really adds to the dark
it makes it really tasty seen as is your
favorite no you can make it i'm gonna do
nothing okay daddy's gonna put his feet
up
so uh first off the garlic there's one
good girl watch your fingers please
always do good
nice oh you're fast huh watch your
fingers
i am watch your fingers
slide slow down please
14. all right that's enough
right a little teaspoon of olive oil in
a few years time i'll be teaching you
how to drive as well as cook how
exciting is that you know in a car
scary okay garlic in
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch
of black beans nice megan and i
add soy sauce and lastly for that
classic chinese sweet and sour element
brown rice vinegar and honey
[Music]
are you happy with the flavour i'm
really happy you can taste everything in
there
dipping sauce done duck's in the oven
let's start the dessert
the most amazing tata tan are those pink
peppercorns
they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything like black peppercorns quite
sweet aren't they they're really sweet
very fruity
the pink peppercorns give it the
sweetness the black peppercorns give
the heat now what is that baby
vanilla this is one of the easiest
desserts in the world to make but one of
the most delicious
it's a sort of take on the classic apple
or pear to tan
but when you caramelize those bananas
with the peppercorns
and the vanilla i bet that tastes
amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay i'm gonna make the caramel start
off with the coal pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally
because i want the butter to stay cold
because i'm gonna stick the bananas in
there okay and then we'll make the
caramel
and caramelize the bananas at the same
time so in goes those
vanilla vanilla seeds pods in there as
well
okay peppercorns done yeah well done
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally yeah nice and
then look
just very carefully sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter well do you
know what want the bananas really
caramelised
you just stuck them between if you cram
them in like this
okay it will stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay it's
all wedged in there
spreading the peppercorns on top of the
bananas so you've got that flavor
in the caramel and the top and the
bottom right
puff pastry puff pastry is difficult and
time consuming to make so
i always buy ready made when i'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type
and keep your pastry cold before using
it
this is where it gets really exciting
you get your fingers you just
pinch the ends so you thin the end if
you do that for me very carefully
have to be quick because the heat your
fingers can melt the pastry
how comes you do it dad because we get
it nice and thin so we can clip it
underneath
now take a spoon and what we do is lift
up that banana and tuck it underneath
see little parcel like a parcel and see
the thin bits of pastry
yeah how easy it is to get it underneath
yeah and that's why you thin them out
you do it so quickly well because i have
to be quick otherwise the pastry will
melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry
that's right see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on we'll start caramelizing that
those three little holes are so
important if we didn't put
a hole in the pastry and it will cause a
lot of steam so the pastry never cooks
it just goes really soggy okay
so really important the caramel is live
now we're working the camel
give a little shake how can you see the
caramel through the pastry
look what happens when it tilts oh yeah
see
all comes running down see yeah nicey
now that pastry okay it's like clinging
on to the bananas
and so when we turn it upside down we've
got this glove full of these caramelised
bananas
look at that wow it looks lucky
look a locky look a locky
ah look at likey got it now baby
is your birthday soon 15. i've just
worked out
i'm my 50th you're 18.
perfect we should do a joint party yeah
love it 12
2 4 for the old ones twelve lunches time
till four for the old one so they can go
to sleep
megan we'll go on later come on perfect
this is where i get excited now look at
the color of that caramel so
tilt the pan again see how dark it is
now yeah
wow it's going a lot darker now it
didn't take long didn't take long at all
that's nearly ready for the oven but
before i put that in i'll get the duck
out
wow how's the duck doing
crispy wow and delicious
how crispy that is it's really crispy
that's what happens when it slow cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven 190
to 200 degrees for our banana tartar tan
time to knock up a quick hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil and to give it that
zingy
asian punch some freshly grated root
[Music]
ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy hoisin dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens
wow look at that so
see now where that pastry is
caramelizing the caramel so dark
and just a little tip gas back on
and that will release it because if you
tip it and it's still sticking
then some of your bananas will stick
yeah
so now see when it starts spinning
around like that
moving around and here we are the moment
of truth
when you know your daddy is the best
chef in the world
ready yep
wow the vanilla
how delicious you look at that amazing
smells really good as well
right start to stand out done crispy
dipping sauce
cucumber salad ready so if you take them
and your dipping sauce
take them over thank you i'll take the
duck don't drop it
promise oh
okay
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes
with a hoisin dressed salad and some
extra oomph from megan's favorite black
bean dipping sauce
you